it's been have to do this the hard way
you must be in a hurry to die Jedi
you know they don't really want to see
this anyway they just want to see my
review you will finish what you've
started I'm just gonna listen go okay
okay
star wars episode 7 the force awakens
has finally arrived yes finally but is
it good force awakens is directed by JJ
Abrams and stars Harrison Ford Mark
Hamill Carrie Fisher Daisy Ridley John
boyega Adam driver tons of great new
people mixed with the old original cast
that we grew up loving this is going to
be a completely spoiler free review I
will eventually do a spoiler filled
review but for anyone who has never
watched a video of mine before know that
I hate ruining things for anyone I
cherish the idea of going to a film with
a sense of discovery as we already know
from the trailers we meet a character
named Ray played by Daisy Ridley she's a
scavenger on the desert planet of jakku
she eventually runs in to John boyega or
Finn a stormtrooper that was part of the
first order which is the new division
that has replaced the old Empire he
decides to leave the first order because
something inside doesn't sit right with
him anymore and he runs into rey on
jakku and they start an adventure
together that eventually leads them to
Han Solo and while all this is happening
there's a new villain on the rise who
has taken great inspiration from Darth
Vader and his name is kylo Ren the last
time a movie was this hyped was probably
the Phantom Menace back in 1999 now I
grew up loving the original trilogy if
you've watched my channel this year
you've seen me review every single
episode leading up to this all the way
from Phantom Menace to return the Jedi
I've had my thoughts about each one but
I've really only loved two of them a new
hope and Empire Strikes Back
well now it's three the force awakens
now look I'm not fanboying here I was
watching this movie like a hawk for
flaws and there are a couple and I'll
talk about them a little bit more in
detail in my spoiler review coming up
very soon the force awakens is one of
the most entertaining movies I've seen
it's not just a great Star Wars movie
it's actually a great film the thing
that I love about force awakens amongst
other things that we'll discuss is the
fact that it actually is a movie with
filmmaking and acting Penn scenes and
characters things we haven't seen in a
Star Wars movie in a really long
I'm action sequences that feel real and
grounded because this production did
have a preference for actual practical
creatures and real designs things that
actually occur right in front of you
that aren't green-screen trickery yes
they're CGI in the movie of course but
it's not the focus another thing I love
about this movie is that it actually has
humor it's very funny it's not stale and
boring and dry and the humor actually
works and some of it is even well
incorporated with the villain characters
John boyega as Finn is so energetic he
has so much charisma you can just feel
it seeping off of him he's so excited to
be in this movie
and it shows in his character he gave an
excellent performance and I really did
care about the character of Finn because
they set him up very well as a person
who just doesn't feel right in his
position you understand why he doesn't
feel right something about what he
witnesses just affects him and you can
feel it even when he's wearing a
stormtrooper helmet and as I said the
adventure that begins with him and Rey
is extremely exciting not just because
of how well directed it is and how much
fun it is and hearing John Williams
brilliant cues again it's also because
you really do care about him as a
character and you also really care about
Rey played by Daisy Ridley who in my
opinion steals the entire film she is
brilliant in this movie she is an
excellent discovery and there is a sense
of discovery going to a movie seeing
someone who's basically unknown
portraying this character and you now
see her as this person because you don't
identify her with something else she's
done in the past her performance is so
real she's so real in this movie you
never feel like she's acting her
characters so well realized and by far
she's the heart and soul of this movie
and she's terrific in the action
sequences as well as is John boyega the
friendship that blossoms between her and
some of the original cast is also tons
of fun and it's the kind of movie where
you don't get much breathe room and that
can be a bad thing in other movies where
you're like wait let's breathe a little
bit and let's sink in here and there are
scenes like that but with this movie and
with the original trilogy most of the
time they're always moving and the plots
always progressing and the plot
progresses through our characters
encountering
more action and that's what force
awakens does for our characters the
prequels everyone walked around and told
us to plot the exposition was so heavy
we were constantly reminded of things
and told directly to the audience rather
than being shown force awakens shows we
get to see these exciting sequences the
exposition is kept to a minimum there
are scenes in this film that I'm sure
people will be like oh why didn't you
explain how that was obtained because
I'm not sure how you got that because
that was kind of lost in another movie
so how'd you get that we'll talk more
about that in a spoiler review it is
glossed over yes but if you complain too
much about those things then you're
really just telling the writers that we
want them to explain everything to us
which is exactly what we told them we
didn't want to do in the prequels so we
have to be careful as fans of Star Wars
to not be hypocritical and expect
everything to be explained to us because
less is more we'll get more into that at
the end of this video one of my favorite
new characters in this movie was Poe
played by Oscar Isaac he is so cool I
mean he just oozes cool he is the
baddest fighter pilot in the galaxy and
he knows it but he's not cocky he's just
really assured of his skills and you
feel that warmth coming off him Oscar
Isaac was excellent in this movie let's
talk about Abraham's direction it was
beautiful long wide takes real practical
explosions as I said the locations are
almost entirely on set on location Abu
Dhabi snowy mountain sides beautiful
forests just a gorgeous looking film
Abrams did a magnificent job directing
it was the perfect choice for this movie
after having seen it I can't think of
someone else helming this film let's
talk about bb-8 no I was worried about
that droid I was concerned you know you
don't want to get too cutesy we've seen
that before Jar Jar Binks didn't work it
was terrible perfect bb-8 is awesome if
you bought bb-8 toys don't feel bad he's
cute and adorable in just the right ways
he's not overbearing he's not annoying
he's not in every scene and they wisely
incorporated some very good humor with
his character I love
the little guy so let's talk about that
original cast Han Solo and Chewie great
stuff the banter between them is there
it's fresh you feel that friendship and
there's this amazing joke that I won't
spoil that goes on back and forth
between the movie about Hans choice of
weaponry loved it so much fun seeing
them back in this movie almost brought
tears to my eyes and not just because oh
look it's Han Solo it was because it was
actually handled well it was giving
respect to the character it wasn't like
hey let's just reference everything from
Star Wars that we liked one time because
this movie had a danger of doing that
and I was afraid of that
Jurassic world did that this year it
tried so hard to pay tribute to Jurassic
Park and it really just came off as
basically copying off of Jurassic Park I
was concerned that Abrams and his love
for a new hope because he has said that
is his favorite would override this
movie and there'd be too many homages to
it there are most definitely scenes or
sequences where you might say okay that
reminds me of Star Wars that reminds me
of Star Wars oh that's an object from a
new hope I remember that but it's not
handled in a derivative way it's handled
in a loving way it's showing respect to
the original trilogy while also being
its own film and that's where I loved
also about Han Solo being back because
he has a role in this movie that's very
integral to the plot and Ford was great
as the character once again it was so
much fun seeing him back with that
blaster and Leia is also back in the
film and the scenes between han and Leia
were really special but also tinged with
a hint of remorse for things in the past
and I just actually thought it was
really beautiful and very well handled
something that Abrams did really well in
this movie was take his time with
certain scenes he pauses a lot on some
of the more heartfelt scenes he doesn't
allow everything to just blur by too
quickly and that's something I really
appreciated
so let's without any spoilers talk about
kylo Ren oh my goodness gracious I love
this guy what a great villain not just
evil and scary and intimidating which he
is but motivated you understand why he's
doing the things that he's doing and
I've said this many times in the past
about the greatest movie villains
they're all characters that you
understand you don't necessarily condone
their actions but you understand why
they think they're doing the right thing
that makes a great villain that makes
one you can actually care about and
almost in a way justify when you see him
or her do certain things and kylo Ren is
just like that he's written very well an
atom driver is amazing as kylo Ren Luke
Skywalker is he in this movie yes I'll
talk to you more in the spoiler review
that's all I'm gonna say about him is
the force awakens a flawless movie well
first of all no movie is if you really
want to pick apart any movie you can
always find a flaw in the storytelling
or something even movies that I've given
a pluses to have problems here are some
of my issues with the film there are so
many real practical effects and real
locations in this movie 99.9% of it is
and it's such a great thing to see but
there are two motion capture characters
and those characters stand out
they are obviously CGI amongst a world
of realism and so I don't always know if
the character of Maz Kanata as well as
Supreme Leader Snoke have a place in
that because as I watched their motion
capture performances
it wasn't like Andy Serkis and Dawn of
the Apes where I was like that's that's
that's real it's a little noticeable and
sometimes distracting but gratefully
they're not in the movie very much at
all and the scenes that they're in while
important are really just propelling the
plot along it's just as I looked at them
I was like that's the CGI oh yeah it
just it didn't really sell for me
unfortunately my other issue is a
spoiler which I will discuss more in my
spoiler review but it's not like a big
plot point it's just something that
occurs in the third act in which
something just sort of randomly goes
like hey I can help and it just happens
and it's so out of left field and you're
just kind of left wondering why that
didn't happen earlier and why it's
happening now and it felt very
convenient and my last and final flaw
with this movie is that I didn't
necessarily feel that Starkiller base
was really all that great it was just
there and it was something that x-wings
had to fight it kind of felt like a
third
star and I don't know I just I didn't
feel that much going in it was like the
the sequence is using it I don't know it
just it didn't really affect me all that
much because it's not really set up as
this terrifying thing it's just there
and they have a base and the x-wings
have to fight something and okay I was
way more invested with what was going on
with our human characters on the ground
and less so much about the Starkiller
base now let's discuss something
something called a cliffhanger a lot of
people are going to leave the force
awakens disappointed they're going to
feel as if something wasn't given to
them they're not going to feel a 100
percent sense of finality
what's another really good Star Wars
movie where it left things like that
well that would be the empire strikes
back in 1980 my dad saw the Empire
Strikes Back in theaters and he told me
that himself and my mom and a lot of
other people he talked to left the
theater disappointed because it was such
a cliffhanger and they had to wait three
years for answers and they felt like
something wasn't right because they
hadn't experienced closure so people
will leave the force awakens thinking
that because yes it sets up for Episode
eight it's not like hey everything's
perfect and wrapped in a little bow
because you know what movies wrapped
everything in a little bow that would be
the Phantom Menace attack of the clones
and Revenge of the Sith every single
prequel and you're like oh it's great
yeah okay do we have to see another one
nothing about each prequel made you go I
want to watch the next one it was always
just an ending and everything was
perfect me we're like okay that's cool
the force awakens hooks you it makes you
want more as I said earlier I would
mention this less is more we want more I
wanted Episode eight to start
instantaneously one Episode seven ended
that means this movie affected me and if
you leave the theater going like that I
want to see bored and that's good you're
supposed to feel that way when we grew
up we could just pop in the next VHS
tape after Empire Strikes Back ended we
got the finality return the Jedi and we
were happy but in 1980 when that movie
ended everyone was like where's the rest
I have to be careful not to mistake my
present-day thoughts of oh I want more
oh my gosh force awakens I need more
because I'm gonna get more they're
making two more it's a start of a
trilogy if we were given complete 100
finality then that would suck I need to
feel hooked I need to feel like I'm
starting a new adventure and when force
awakens ended I was just like more now
she has the original trilogy Episode
four or five and six went on each film
answered more questions and gave us more
questions until finally returned the
Jedi gave us closure as the prequels
went on the film's tried to answer
questions but they really just muddled
it even more the force awakens
gives us questions and it makes us want
the answers and I can't wait to
experience the answers now I know you
guys want me to do you want me to rank
them I can't have only seen it one time
I have to see it again but by far I know
for a fact this is my favorite Star Wars
film since the Empire Strikes Back
I do like it more than return the Jedi I
don't know if I like it more than Empire
or Star Wars I'd have to see it multiple
more times it's a billion times better
than the prequels and as I said better
than return the Jedi I think it's a
great Star Wars film and I'm not phantom
menacing here I was watching like a hawk
for flaws and there are some but it
didn't affect my enjoyment of this film
it didn't affect the entertainment value
present in the force awakens guys
virtually every scene in this film is
brimming with ideas with creativity and
it would be really dumb of me not to
acknowledge that as someone who
appreciates filmmaking as someone who
appreciates imagination this film
launches a whole new generation of Star
Wars fans and characters while still
paying great tribute to the old as well
as making us want more of the new I'm
gonna give Star Wars The Force awakens
and eh I told you guys in detail my pros
and cons now I will talk about the
spoilers very soon in my spoiler review
and please stay tuned for my secret
surprise Star Wars review that will
launch in a couple days after I post my
spoiler review I can't wait to do that
also some very important thank you thank
you so much to my friend Matthew Brando
for portraying kylo Ren in my opening
skit he did a great job I have left a
link for his channel below we've done
some Star Wars videos together because
he reviews Star Wars toy
jurassic park toys he talks about
blu-rays and filmmaking and other cool
things on his channel he's a good friend
of mine thank you so much to Aaron J
Morton for providing the score for that
skit he did an amazing job he also has
provided the composure for my opening
theme great guy thank you so much and
Kevin a yacht for helping me the last
possible minute with some of those
visual effects I was able to do my green
lightsaber and then I was just like I
can't focus on this I I need to do other
things you did amazing work with those
visual effects thank you so much sir I
have left a link for his information
below because he would like to do this
for a living and I think he should
because he did an amazing job thank you
sir and last but not least a very cool
youtuber Taylor Davis has composed an
awesome Star Wars violin song that will
be uploaded very soon that link is going
to be in the description below but for
now it's going to be her channel as well
as that video link eventually right
below that please definitely go check
that out guys
Star Wars look forward to it I'm gonna
go see it again Thursday at 7:00 you
guys are the best
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes